[музика]
вітаємо Ласкаво просимо до програми
Європа У фокусі з вами я Ліз шу люди по
всій Європі відчувають святковий настрій
прикрашені ялинки приносять особливу
різдвяну атмосферу у міста і села по
всьому континенту люди натовпами
відвідують ярмарки це ідеальне місце щоб
зустрітися з друзями випити чогось
гарячого чи навіть купити щось в останні
хвилини перед
святом це також та пора року одне
питання задають дуже часто де живе
санта-клаус мабуть десь на півночі де
холодно і сніжно що ж одразу декілька
країн претендують на звання справжньої
домівки Санти у Фінляндії переконані що
це місто рованіємі за Полярним колом це
справжній туристичний магніт багато хто
приїжджає до цього маленького селища
щороку але жителі рованіємі хочуть
досягти балансу між туризмом і довкіллям
Санта Клаус існує принаймні у цьому
фінському селі на полярному
колі Санта зайнятий читає листи роздає
подарунки і зустрічається з дітьми та
дорослими з усього
світу Він і його зимова Країна чудес
стали однією із найважливіших
туристичних цікавинок
Фінляндії Вільний від роботи час
любить проводити на
природі одна з моїх улюблених речей
звісно влітку - це прогулянки в
лісі Іноді я ходжу з моїм найкращим
другом рудольфом знаєте з таким червоним
носом а іноді ми гуляємо з
ельфами природа - це частина магії у
селі санта-клауса екскурсія на оленячих
опряжках або катання з їздовими хаскі
користується великою популярністю серед
тури
і Звісно ж просто перебування на
полярному колі у селищі яке було
засновано у 1950 роках неподалік від
міста рованіємі тут стає дедалі більше
людей близько 300 000 осіб щороку
приїжджають сюди аби відсвяткувати
Різдво
по-особливому ніколи не відчувала нічого
подібного Санта він класний добрий А ще
він красивий це ніби трохи магії у
повсякденному
житті але лі сюди проживання і всі ці
різдвяні подарунки впливають на фінське
місто і на
[музика]
довкілля подорожі та туризм звісно
виробляють багато вуглекислого
газу тому багато готелів Тут роблять усе
можливе аби мінімізувати такий вплив і
зробити туризм тут сталим йхані іконен
тримає в місті готель який використовує
лише геотермальну енергію від тепла
землі і має майже нульові викиди інші
використовують старі матеріали замість
нових думати про майбутнє це ще й
економічно
вигідно наприклад ви хочете займатися
якимось зимовим бізнесом або чимось
пов'язаним із
природою але ж якщо ви руйнуватимете
природу то недовго зможете цим
займатися Ви повинні думати про майбутнє
Тені готелі подають заявки на отримання
сертифікатів сталості до фінського уряду
і належать до туристичного кооперативу
який спільно працює над зменшенням
викидів інші роблять Іще один крок
піклуються про вірних супутників Санти
північних оленів поїздка на упряжці з
оленями одне із найяскравіших вражень
для багатьох туристів але ці тварини
особливо вразливі до кліматичних змін їх
не можна тримати в хлівах в ідеалі вони
повинні бути на свіжому повітрі на
пасовищі це допомагає їм а також лісам
залишатися здоровими пасучись вони
підстригають рослини і допомагають їм
відростати здоровішими для корінного
оленяра ярко пеки олонена олені - це
щось більше ніж просто робочі
тварини це мабуть найдобріший олень у
світі зараз сталі готелі співпрацюють
лише з оленями яких вирощують корінні
жителі за межами міста це допомагає
тваринам лісам а також корінному
населенню саамам зберігати свої
[музика]
традиції у нас близько 20
оленів вранці у нас ранкове сафарі на
оленях а вночі полярне сафарі на
оленях хто працює ввечері той не працює
вранці так ми можемо дбати про здоров'я
цих оленів і піклуватися про те щоб вони
також могли відпочити
відпочинок - це те чого не вистачає
помічникам Санти напередодні Різдва
особливо тим хто відповідає за поштове
відділення Санти щороку санта-клаусу
приходять тисячі листів приблизно з 200
країн світу відправлення листа поштою
порівняно із подорожжу це безумовно
більш екологічний варіант і поштові
відділення здається готові цьому
посприяти вони кажуть нам якщо ви
напишете на листі Санта Клаус і
відправите його з будь-якої точки світу
то він потрапить саме сюди Різдво - це
час радощів і це фінське містечко працює
над тим щоб воно таким і залишалося
Санті теж є що
сказати якщо ви дбаєте про природу
природа подбає про
вас а також якщо ви дбаєте про інших
людей інші люди будуть дбати про
вас це ніби мати відчуття Різдва у
своєму серці увесь час
[оплески]
[музика]
дістатися до іделічного місця не завжди
легко Візьміть наприклад ці кам'яні
сходи вони ведуть до дуже особливого
місця в італійських Альпах людям які
хочуть потрапити до цього крихітного
села кодера доведеться йти туди пішки ця
кам'яниста пригода не для всіх і вона
може бути виснажливою але у місцевих
мешканців таких як Єлена ролі немає
вибору Це її повсякденне життя вона одна
із небагатьох хто іще живе в цьому селі
і вона не підтримує будівництво дороги
до
кодери Високо над озером Комо
знаходиться кодера ізольоване село в
Альпах усього дев'ять людей досі живуть
тут Елена гузмеролі та її остерія опора
цієї маленької громади до села можна
дістатися лише двома шляхами гузмеролі
віддає перевагу двогодинному пішому
маршруту з долини на березі озера Комо
2600 сходинок у
гору стрес який накопичується коли я
спускаюся в Долину Тане поки я
піднімаюся вгору Це чудово коли я
потрапляю в кодеру Я відчуваю таку
легкість
є ще другий варіант
гелікоптер але він обходиться приблизно
у 300 євро за політ тому Елена
користується лише тоді коли потрібно
доставити в село їжу або інші товари для
себе та
інших Я везу речі для альфонси для
Джуліано щось для всіх продукти хліб
бразаолу салямі і золенини усього
потроху Всього за дві хвилини Все це
приземляється у мальовничій кодері на
висоті 824 м над рівнем
моря
тут немає доріг мешканці цієї маленької
сільської громади останні у своєму роді
Хто живе в Альпах цілий рік у такій
ізоляції кози Девіса піснолі пасуться
десь високо у
горах у свої 45 років він наймолодший
житель кодери і він прагне змін Я за
дорогу Так ми зможемо зберегти село
живим ставитися до нього як до казкового
ландшафту чи місця з листівки що
застрягло в часі це не
допоможе адже жити в такій ізоляції це
зовсім не романтично каже піснолі тільки
людям які не живуть тут постійно
здається що це
так і
туристи для туристів це
рай але я бачу що село
вмирає Ну що тут
робити ким
працювати Якби була дорога Можна було б
добувати каміння рубати ліс але якби все
це потрапляло в
Долину на наших плечах як
зараз і все ж Девіс планує залишатися
тут зі своїми козами тому що він любить
гори після того як гелікоптер скидає
свій вантаж Елена повинна донести їжу до
своєї остерії ні дороги Ні будь-яких
інших засобів транспортування тільки її
спина
це важко але воно того варте це дає вам
так багато моментів які приносять
задоволення це про
взаємність Ну я
пішла до її остерії альпіна У центрі
села і до альфонси пеноне найстарша
жителька села провела в кодері майже все
своє життя колись тут жило приблизно 600
людей альфонса бачила як село повільно
вимирає вона постаріла разом із
ним мені майже
[оплески]
95 Я ніколи не
палила ніколи не їла надто жирної
їжі вона сподівається побачити як люди
повертаються
сюди Було б добре якби тут побудували
дорогу
тут багато місця Можна було б побудувати
більше будинків і тоді більше людей
могло б тут
жити будемо сподіватися що Дорогу скоро
збудують щоб не сталося альфонса хоче
залишитися у рідному селі тут високо над
озером Комо Гус моролі починає працювати
на кухні в острії альпіна завдяки
асоціації Друзі кодери її ресторан
працює цілий рік і користується великою
популярністю вона вважає що саме
віддаленість кокудери робить її
привабливою не всі доходять сюди цією
крутою стежкою ті хто все ж підіймаються
відчувають зв'язок із горами і їм
подобається те що піднятися сюди - це
важка
праця це відчуття треба заслужити і мені
це
подобається Якщо жителі села вирішать що
їм потрібна дорога я буду поважати це
але це більше не буде моїм
місцем поки що ніяких планів щодо дороги
немає Тож кудера ймовірно ще довго
залишатиметься селом На краю
світу Зараз ми познайомимо вас із брджет
мош яка називає себе бigі більшу частину
свого життя вона провела в дорозі бі
одна із небагатьох жінок що водять
вантажівки у Європі сотні тисяч таких
вакансій відкриті частково через те що
це дуже важка робота але це ніколи не
хвилювало біі вона працює водійкою уже
30 років жінка долає всі труднощі які
трапляються на її
шляху Добрий ранок бігі вітається із
Едді своєю вантажівкою вона належить
компанії але тільки бігі дозволено
керувати нею брджет мош заступає на
зміну усього й побільше
сюди наступні пть днів бігі їздитиме
їстиме і спатиме на скромних кваметра
салону
вантажівки мені просто це подобається це
Я не можу описати мені просто тут дуже
добре Вона за кермом уже 30 років
сьогодні перші 50 кмт бігі проїде без
причепа дорогою до свого першого вантажу
вона виявляє що під'їзна дорога
заблокована чорт
забирай доведеться їхати іншою
дорогою Чи я зможу пройти А я
пройду чи не
пройду тісно але бігі знає свого
Едді проблему вирішено час для наступної
о вони вже розвантажуються я не можу
під'їхати до свого трейлера трейлер біг
ліворуч а інший стоїть праворуч проїхати
ніяк Я мушу розвернутися і заїхати задом
через
склад проїхати заднім ходом через склад
повний перешкод - це дуже тонка робота
повільне і точне маневрування щоб
з'єднатися із причепом сьогоднішній
вантаж спеціальна Промислова
[оплески]
фарба О Боже
мій нічим не гірше за
спортзал Настав час випити кави поки
Вода закипає бігі займається
формальностями тут написано 7:00 А ми
були тут раніше 7ї щойно ми закінчили
під'єднуватися вона зберігає все для
свого роботодавця на бортовому
комп'ютері Катерина боймле молодша
менеджерка компанії знаходиться у
головному офісі бортовий комп'ютер
вантажівки дозволяє Їй завжди точно
знати де і коли знаходяться біі та
Едді тут ви бачите що Минулого понеділка
був дуже щільний трафік вона могла
проїхати всього 4 км за 50 хвилин тому
сильно запізнилася коли ми бачимо це то
можемо реагувати і вирішувати що робити
далі
тобто тут ви можете стежити за всім
так для компанії перевізника важливо все
відстежувати зрештою у них 160
вантажівок на рейсах але їм не вистачає
водіїв катеріна разом з батьками
переглядає нові заявки на
роботу молодша менеджерка сподівається
найняти більше
жінок-водійок взаєми не складаються
по-різному наприклад у конфліктни я
сподіваюся будуть рідкісними у мене були
жінки які вибачалися на наступний день
тому що вони були не в настрої таке
буває але не з чоловіками тож це інша
форма взаємин та обидві статі можуть
виконувати свою роботу однаково
добре тим не менш лише троє зі 180
водіїв жінки бос вважає що це занадто
мало нам загалом потрібно більше
людей тому ми раді кожній людині яка
приєднується до нас кому це подобається
хто бачить цю роботу як
покликаня і неважливо яка їхня стать
50 км уже позаду і кавабрейк біги
закінчився їй та Едді час знову вирушати
в дорогу у цю справу треба вкладати душу
і серце інакше нічого не вийде Я кермую
вантажівками не тому що мушу а тому що
хочу Візьміть наприклад
мою вантажівку Звісно це вантажівка але
він також мій напарник ми працюємо разом
коли йому погано мені теж погано Так
само як і в партнерстві Я одружена на
своїй
вантажівці якби у мене був партнер який
сказав би мені що я маю покинути цю
справу Я б сказала Ні я не піду Іди геть
водіння - Це моє
життя любов бігі до водіння коштувала їй
двох шлюбів Це її не турбує але вона
глибоко шкодує що більше не не бачить
своїх двох доньок Я ніколи не була поруч
із ними лише по телефону Я ніколи не
тримала їх на
руках зараз жінка приїхала ближче до
своїх доньок вона не хоче прогавити ще й
можливість бачитися із онуками Та це не
означає що вона збирається покинути свою
улюблену роботу поки що бігі та Едді
будуть і далі долати кілометри
[музика]
доріг Робі та Крістоф пара їхня мрія
знайти справжнє кохання стала реальністю
багатьом людям із ментальними розладами
Це дається нелегко це тому що їм часто
доводиться стикатись з унікальними
викликами деяким із них важко навіть
піти на побачення без супроводу
доглядача Стефані партунс із Бельгії
Хоче змінити це тому вона створила
додаток для знайомства людей із
особливими потребами її платформа
madelde допомагає користувачам які
шукають партнера і попит на неї досить
великий Я кохаю
тебе і я тебе кохаю і ти це
знаєш Крістоф і Робі закухані по вуха
обом трохи за 30 Крістоф працює у
майстерні а Робі допомагає у центрі
денного
догляду не одразу помітно наскільки
складним для них може бути повсякденне
життя Крістоф і Робі мають ментальні
порушення і живуть у різних групах для
людей із особливими
потребами вони можуть дбати про деякі
речі самостійно але потребують
присутності доглядача щоб прожити день і
щоб зробити можливими зустрічі один з
одним ми познайомилися на танцювальному
заході який влаштовували
мамедалівде
моя доглядальниця сказала мені що
знайшла декого хто мені
підходить щойно вони зустрілися обоє
зрозуміли що створені один для
одного це відбулося в одну
мить цей Вогник загорівся дуже швидко з
обох сторін вони знайшли один одного за
допомогою платформи маделівде ця
ініціатива працює трохи не так як інші
сайти
таки як н чи бамл маделівде призначений
для самотніх людей із особливими
потребами які шукають собі партнерів це
творіння соціальної працівниці Стефані
паркінс досить часто у додатках для
знайомстви на сайтах знайомства
трапляються випадки
домагань або спроби насильства або з
тебе
сміються особливо важко знайти партнера
людями з розумовими
розладами
Багатьом із них потрібна певна допомога
щоб прийти на побачення
Стефані та її колеги соціальні
працівники із різних спеціалізованих
закладів Фландрії збирають анкети та
організовують зустрічі де самотні люди
можуть познайомитись у невимушеній
атмосфері і ці зусилля мали успіх і з
моменту запуску у 2022 році вони зібрали
понад 200
анкет де люди з ментальними порушеннями
можуть надсилати свої профілі
електронною або звичайною поштою вони
вказують що шукають і чому хотіли б
побудувати стосунки ми порівнюємо
профілі і намагаємося знайти відповідну
пару 32хрічна Андрея запросила нас до
своєї оселі де за нею
доглядають Я б хотіла мати хлопця із
яким можна було б кудись піти і весело
провести
час жінка дуже цінує гостинність але до
неї не часто приходять
гості я можу підготувати закуски і буде
шампанське конвенція он щодо прав людей
з інвалідністю закликає кожну державу
забезпечувати можливості для людей з
інвалідністю вступати в
стосунки Незважаючи на це таких людей як
Андрея часто маргіналізують маделівде
допомагає подолати стереотипи та
бар'єри
дослідження проведене бельгійською
організацією за рівність проти
дискримінації показало що більшість
людей з інвалідністю відчувають утиски у
вираженні своєї
сексуальності їхні потреби в цьому сенсі
рідко визнаються суспільством синція і
Пітер тільки нещодавно дізналися про
маделівде Пітер радий що з'явилася така
можливість Але не зовсім задоволений
нею Добре що є мамедалівди
робть ля хорошу роботу але розчаровує те
що ми не можемо Знайти партнерів на
більш звичних
сайтах коли я дивлюся на свою сестру та
її чоловіка з їхнім будинком садом і
собакою я думаю що хотіла б мати усе це
теж
Робі і Крістоф Здається знайшли своє
велике кохання без маделівде це навряд
чи було б можливим вони можуть
зустрічатися лише раз на місяць у їхніх
доглядальників багато інших клієнтів тим
не менш вони щовечора розмовляють по
телефону і навіть планують
одружитися Я би хотів приїхати на
весілля на класичній машині Я готовий до
цього я
теж але парі доведеться почекати роки
щоб їхні опікуни могли бути впевнені що
це кохання буде дійсно
довговічним столиця Португалії Лісабон
багата на туристичні місця серед них
унікальні міські кіоски які зазвичай
розташовані в парках або на центральних
площах люди збираються там іще з 19го
століття сьогодні серед туристів це
популярні місця для знімків
тяго алвестримає такий кіоск і знає все
про їхню багату історію для нього це
більше ніж просто місце де можна випити
кави Чи почитати газету це частина
культурної спадщини яку потрібно
зберігати
А на сьогодні це все Веселих свят і до
зустрічі у наступному випуску Європа У
фокусі I